- Technology and the
way we live doesn't care
about my opinion or my feelings
and it doesn't care about yours either.
And so you can walk
around earth and judge,
"Oh, it's so sad that all
these kids can't communicate,
"'cause they're on the phone anymore."
And you can talk about a day
and age when it was simpler,
and nicer, and all this,
nobody gives a fuck.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
And if you don't adjust to
the reality of the situation,
you will be completely left behind.
Too many people are executing, or hoping,
or trying to figure out
how to live in a world
that used to be or the
way they wish it was,
versus attacking the reality of the world.
And here is the reality
of the world my friends.
The cellphones that you're
all holding right now,
or in your pocket, are the
remote controls of our society.
They are the single most
important thing in the world.
There's nothing close.
Whatever you want to happen in life,
you first need somebody's attention,
and then you need to tell them about it.
It was called the newspaper,
the television, and the radio.
Now it's called a blog,
a vlog, or a podcast.
It's the same thing, nothing's
changed except one thing.
Your attention is moving to a new place,
and leaving an old place.
I'm making this very simple,
very black and white, very fucking basic.
If you do not spend next year
completely obsessing over
how you become successful
on Facebook and Instagram,
you will be disproportionally
less likely to win.
The ad product on those two platforms
are disproportionally underpriced,
and that that is where
you should be trading.
You are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now.
98% of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is, right?
You will look back at this talk,
all my content during this era,
why am I producing so much
content during this era?
Why am I flying around the
entire world over and over,
speaking to this subject?
It's because I know what
I'm talking about right now,
is gonna go away.
And I think we can all agree,
I'm not hedging up here right now.
(audience chuckling)
I'm desperately trying to force this
down your fucking mouth, right?
You heard it, and I believe that 95%
of you will not do anything about it.
You'll do enough to make it
feel like you did something,
and you will regret not going all in.
How many people here play poker?
Good, I don't, but if you do,
when you have the best hand,
it's a good idea to go all in.
I'm a great entrepreneur
but I think I'm even better
at consumer behavior and psychology.
It's who I am, it's why
a lot of you follow me,
because when you cut me down
you see that I'm pushing positivity,
and a whole lot of other
things that matter,
and trying to get people
to do it the right way.
Be patient, do the
right thing, dadadadada.
The thing that people have
not wrapped their head around,
is that this takes a lot
of work, like a lot a lot.
If you want to make $100,000
a year and like doing it,
and it's on your terms,
and it's your life,
it takes a lot of work, and
it takes a lot of smart work.
You've never met anybody in your life
who hasn't worked their
face off for a long time
that's built something significant.
It may seem that it happened
fast 'cause they're 27,
but maybe they've been
hustling since they were 13
in a different way that gave
them 14 years of experience
to be a winner in that game.
Everybody's so worried about tomorrow
that it doesn't allow them
to see what's actually happening here.
And that why I always
recommend people spending time
with older people, retirement home.
I'm a big fan because you get
to see regret and resentment up close,
and it starts to help you frame up a life.
In life we're all born
with either an advantage or disadvantage.
We either started with too much,
or we started with too little,
and then basically, you know,
your internal fortitude decides
if that was good or bad.
You know, listen man, to
be very honest with you,
I'll give you answer.
You have no choice, that's how.
What's the alternative?
When you have a setback,
what are you gonna sit there
and say it was your granddad and your dad?
I mean, you know that's not true.
It's why you have so many wins, right?
So just practice.
I just kept practicing
blaming myself for everything.
Now I just default into it.
I think you just have now choice, brother.
Listen, I'll leave you guys with this.
Doing anything that doesn't ring true
down your entire
operating system and soul,
because you think you need to do it
based on somebody's
advice that you admire,
or because you have
short-term pain in your life,
is never going to work.
It has never worked, it doesn't work,
and it's just better to wrap your head
around enjoying the short-term
pain, and I mean that.
Listen, the Rocky movies that
are good is when it's shitty,
not when he's in the fancy mansion.
If you're sitting with
some adversity right now,
it's yours, right?
No matter what your
adversity is, we all have it.
And so please, please wrap your head
around what we're actually doing here.
And more importantly,
if you were smart enough
to be here today, and I mean this.
The fact that you came here today
puts you so far ahead of everybody else,
and I hate knowing for a fact
that so many of you are going
to give up your advantage,
because you like hearing me say it,
and you like the way it feels,
but then you leave and you
don't do anything about it.
So please Brisbane, do me a favor,
go do something about this talk today.
I implore you, it will change
the course of your career.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(soft music)